Have you ever watched a presentation of iPhone emperor Steve Jobs?
Many people admit that his presentations are concise and powerful.
He is a good example of someone who shows us how to make an impressive presentation to audiences.
So, how can we imitate him?
"Practice makes perfect" is a cliche but ever so true.
Yet, how do you exactly practice and prepare for a presentation?
Against common advice, it is best not to practice in front of a mirror...
...as it will distract you and make you more self-conscious.
Use an area that resembles the actual location, and videotape your attempts.
Use the camera as the audience!
You don't have to worry about making mistakes during the mock presentation.
Because we are often not the best judges of our own work,...
...show the delivery to family, friends or even a professional and get some feedback.
Moreover, focus on areas where you might stumble over words.
Some sentences look great on paper but can in practice be tongue twisters...
...and some jokes may not hit the mark.